I've got a recommendation today that
recommendation is for a documentary
called foodies the culinary jet said
this is on Amazon it is also on netflix
it's a documentary about what i would
call fine dining subculture and it
follows a number of self-described or in
some cases not self-described but
described by others foodies around the
world they travel to the most expensive
Michelin restaurants many of these
people are clearly very very wealthy
some of them are only wealthy and it was
absolutely fascinating to me number one
because I'm really interested in in how
some of these high-end restaurants
operate and do marketing and it's just
so different than what you would
normally consider to be the advertising
plan for a restaurant but I couldn't
decide as I was watching this whether I
should be really really fascinated and
interested in the lives of these
so-called foodies or whether I should be
incredibly angry and consider throwing
my computer out the window because of
the adjusting the same uh pretension
that exists within this community and if
you watch it you need to be ready for
some cringe-worthy pretentious stuff as
you're watching this film and I'd be
curious to hear from the audience sort
of what what you think about it uh
because although I was definitely
fascinated by it and I've been to I've
never been to a Michelin star restaurant
but I've been to some nice restaurants
where you have a tasting menu or
whatever and even at that level I'm
already when they come over and they say
uh would you like me to send over the
sommelier to make some wine
recommendations I get it there's an
expert in the wine but something about
me too says uh-uh it doesn't feel right
to be here there's something that is
feeling very very privileged and like I
don't belong here and to be honest if
anyone is used to this it's hard to
imagine them being completely in touch
with the perils of the average man or
woman in our country uh but that that's
just my reaction because I have such a
visceral sort of uh I'm very much off
put put off I guess the right word is
by that entire world check it out send
me your thoughts on it is again called
foodies the culinary jet set it's on
Netflix it's on Amazon streaming and you
can see all of our recommendations at
david pakman.com slash recommendations